in the opening scene we are introduced
to the protagonist Jake green who has
achieved significant success in the
world of gambling after spending seven
years in solitary confinement in prison
he was released two years ago despite
his past accomplishments he returned to
the gambling world with no money and had
to work his way up again but currently
he is one of the most influential
figures in the business working
alongside his brother Billy who also
serves as his assistant in the next
scene Jake and Billy enter a casino
owned by their adversary Dorothy matcha
since Jake is known for never losing and
gambling the dealer denies him a table
matcha upon learning of Jake's arrival
insists on meeting him disregarding his
bodyguard Paul's advice to access the
Upper Floor of the casino Jake must take
an elevator but he is hesitant due to
his claustrophobia resulting from nearly
a decade of solitary confinement however
after much consideration and support
from his brother he eventually takes the
elevator it's a stupid thing to be
afraid of anyway later he confronts
matcha in the to engage in a game of
gambling Jake loses the first round
deliberately which gives matcha a sense
of false accomplishment however in the
subsequent round with higher Stakes Jake
skillfully wins much to matcha's dismay
following this Jake and Billy leave the
casino with all the money they've won
moments after their departure the casino
owner hires his top assassin sorter to
eliminate Jake perceiving him as a great
threat to the business on his way out
Jake comes across a guy named Zach who
warns him that he is in danger and
offers assistance leaving behind his
card This Time Jake chooses to use the
stairs but he abruptly loses
Consciousness and falls down them now
he's afraid of stairs too ironically the
card given by Zach consists of an
instruction for him to take the elevator
then Jake is rushed to the hospital
where doctors conduct tests and advise
him to consult the laboratory later for
the results upon arriving back home Jake
discovers a note on his doorstep
instructing him to pick it up as he
bends down to reach the note he is
bushed by sorter who fires the first
shot this leads to a fierce shootout
between his bodyguards and the attackers
putting Jake's life in grave danger but
fortunately Zach intervenes and rescues
Jake revealing that he was the one who
left the note Zach then takes Jake to
his partner Avi who surprisingly knows a
lot about Jake's background he reveals
something shocking that Jake's past
Hospital reports indicate that he has a
rare blood disease that can kill him
within three days at most Avi and Zach
propose to Shield him from matcha's
threats and find a way to treat his
illness only if he hands over all the
money he earned from gambling over the
past two years with no viable options
from conventional doctors Jake
reluctantly agrees and hands over his
hard-earned money meanwhile sorter is
distressed because it is his first time
missing a Target matcha provides him
with a second chance also threatening to
take his life if he fails you're the
most useful man in the world to me but I
will kill you throughout the journey
Jake's inner voice comes to life it
turns out he has been hearing this voice
ever since he was imprisoned and he is
forced to obey it every time elsewhere
Abby and Zach disclose their true
identities as alone sharks intending to
lend the money they collected from Jake
Jake who is in no place to argue
accompanies them as they deal with their
debtors eventually Avi inquires about
Jake's history with matcha a flashback
delves into Jake's past before his
imprisonment revealing that matcha had
three loyal Associates known as the
Eddies who carried out his illicit tasks
initially Jake was just a regular
Gambler on the streets until the Eddies
asked him to be a card man for matcha
Jake played on matcha's behalf and won
but things took a violent turn when an
opponent insulted him leading to a
shootout as a consequence of the
shootout matcha lost money as well as
his henchmen in retaliation the Eddies
who were loyal to matcha murdered
Billy's wife and threatened to harm
Jake's niece as well following this Jake
was arrested and imprisoned due to his
involvement in the violent incident at
present matcha is trying to land a
business deal with a wealthy and
dangerous businessman Named Sam gold
however gold never shows up in person
and always operates through his
representative Lily Walker making him a
mysterious figure Lily cautions matcha
about the severe repercussions if he
disappoints or tries to deceive gold the
deal involves a legal powder importation
which excites matcha primarily due to
the substantial financial gain it
promises but also because he loves
putting powder in his bomb in the next
scene Jake shares his prison experience
with Avi and Zach it turns out that he
was given a choice between serving a
regular 14-year sentence or seven years
in solitary confinement the prison was
happy to release the prisoner early so
long as they become insane first
expectedly he chose the latter and was
placed in a small cell between two other
inmates a con artist and a chess expert
he never saw the two of them were talked
directly but communicated through a
shared communal book which contains
secret message the clever and dangerous
Duo of the chess expert and con artist
taught Jake various techniques and
skills of a perfect con through their
cryptic messages although he learned a
lot from them he couldn't completely
grasp the full extent of their
communication during his fifth year the
two prisoners planned an escape and
agreed to take Jake with them but they
disappeared the very next morning
leaving him behind the police couldn't
locate them as if they had vanished Into
Thin Air after his release Jake
discovered that the escaped convicts had
stolen all the money he had hidden
outside the prison they left behind a
message stating you can only get
schmalter by playing a smarter opponent
over Time Jake applied the tricks he
learned from them to become a gambling
King as he is now in the present time
Abby and Zach attentively listened to
Jake's narrative without showing any
immediate reaction a few moments later
they mentioned that they have an
important task to accomplish the task
involves stealing the powder that matcha
was supposed to supply to Gold later the
trio successfully completes the task
putting matcha in a lot of trouble the
latter becomes so worried that he is
forced to seek assistance from a rival
Crime Boss named Lord John who agrees to
sell him another batch of powder at
Double the market price desperate to
save himself from Gold's potential wrath
Macho reluctantly accepts the deal the
intense situation escalates when Avi
Zach Jake and their Associates interrupt
the deal-making process at the hotel and
is successfully incapacitate everyone
present and managed to steal the goods
before matcha's henchmen can secure the
powder as a result of the deception both
matcha and Lord John suspect each other
of treachery leading them to conspire
against one another while the actual
culprits evade suspicion in the next
scene we see Abby and Jake engaging in a
game of chess using the cunning
strategies he acquired during his prison
days Jake outwits Avi every time after
this he is taken to confront the debtor
as usual but this time he is asked to
shoot a man who didn't repay his debt on
time the voice in his head urges him to
comply claiming that it's not a big deal
but for the first in his life Jake
resists the voice and refuses to shoot
he even attempts to fire at Avi when the
man tries to retaliate but the gun
happens to be unloaded following this
he's knocked out with a blow to the back
of his head when Jake awakens the next
morning he finds himself back in bed
perplexed as to why he was spared it is
now the fourth day since the last Health
reports and when he goes for a follow-up
with the doctor he is informed that he
was simply misdiagnosed turns out he's
not going to die after all after this
Jake confronts Avi and Zach filled with
determination to seek answers strangely
the voice in his head persists
suggesting that the duo is playing mind
games with him much to Jake's surprise
Avi seems to have heard the voice as
well however now he clarifies that the
voice is not actually his but an
opponent disguising themselves as a
friend adhering to the principles of a
perfect con here a revelation unfolds
exposing the mysterious and feared
businessman Sam gold as an illusion
instead of being an sexual person in
reality Sam gold is a metaphor
camouflaged fear ego and evil residing
within the minds of every individual
despite leaving prison physically Jake
appears to have remained imprisoned by
the imaginary Sim gold ever since
realizing that he has been manipulated
by The Voice Jake engages in a fierce
internal struggle to resist its
influence the voice urges him to end
everything including his biggest
adversary matcha however Jake resists Su
coming to Pride and instead chooses to
apologize to matcha defying the voices
Sinister instructions throughout his
mental battle matcha is also contending
with his own inner struggles driven by
The Voice Jake's unexpected apology
leaves matcha bewildered that the voice
insists that it's merely a mockery
following this Jake also chooses to face
his claustrophobia by entering an
elevator despite the elevator stopping
Midway and triggering his fear he
courageously fights and overcomes the
voices attempts to defeat him elevators
are a stupid fear anyway when the
elevator finally opens matcha stands
before him pointing a gun at him Jake is
unfazed by the threat and his
fearlessness surprises matcha allowing
his voice to take control of his actions
matcha fails to realize who the real Sam
gold is and becomes consumed by the
irrational fear that he will be hunted
down by this fictional entity the
following day Jake takes a bold step and
makes a substantial donation to a
charity in mocha's name going against
Sam gold one more time later on matcha
appears puzzled by the media attention
but he gladly accepts the credit and
recognition before long he also
discovers that it was Jake and his group
who sabotaged his deal with Sam gold
earlier fueled by anger he orders his
men to find and kill Jake however the
gangsters instead find Jake's brother
Billy and Denise Rachel at his home they
then subject Billy to torture and plan
to abduct the girl meanwhile the
Assassin's sorter also experiences a
transformation similar to that of Jake
as a result of this he decides to defy
macha's men and protect Rachel sadly
sorter's Act of Courage leads to death
as one of the gang members ultimately
kills him and abducts Rachel taking her
to matcha meanwhile Avi and Zach escort
Jake to matcha's casino there he plays
chess against Avi and realizes that the
latter was merely pretending to be a
poor player and could have won at any
time upon thinking deeply Jake
eventually understands that Avi and Zach
are none other than the very prison
inmates who betrayed him two years ago
and nobody saw this twist coming here it
becomes evident that the guys have
fulfilled their promise to free Jake
from a different kind of prison not a
physical one but the confinement of his
own mind Avi and Zach also reveal that
they didn't assist Jake out of affection
but because they represent his wisdom
and higher self counteracting Sam gold
who symbolizes his fears in the final
scene Jake goes to matcha who has taken
Rachel hostage and possesses both
batches of stolen powder despite
offering to return the powder matcha
seems lost and controlled entirely by
the voice inside his mind he places the
gun on Rachel's had hoping to provoke a
reaction from Jake when Jake remains
composed matcha becomes infuriated
eventually the Sam gold inside him
screams in Rage that turns into fear
making him realize that it will engulf
him soon unable to comprehend that the
return of the powder could save him
matcha succumb
to come anik and ultimately commits the
unthinkable allowing Sam gold to win the
movie serves as an illustration of the
inner battle against negative thoughts
which can be overcome through
determination each person carries their
own Sam gold urging them to nurture ego
and pride the outcome depends on the
individual's Choice whether to succumb
to negative thoughts like matcha or to
confront them like Jake subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching